[Musique]
et donc nous sommes heureux de
t'accueillir ce soir ici et le
chancelier schols me rejoint ce soir et
je n'en remercie pour que nous puissions
ensemble t'exprimer notre solidarité
notre soutien notre volonté
d'accompagner l'Ukraine vers la victoire
vers la paix et vers l'Europe l'Ukraine
peut compter sur la France ses
partenaires européens et ses alliés pour
gagner la guerre
la Russie ne peut ni ne doit l'emporter
aussi longtemps qu'elle attaquera il
sera nécessaire que nous poursuivions
adaption modulons le soutien militaire
nécessaire à la préservation de
l'Ukraine et de son avenir
de même que nous avons procédé ces
dernières semaines à de nouvelles
livraisons de matériel de défense nous
poursuivrons l'effort et nous évoquerons
ce soir ensemble les besoins
opérationnels de l'Ukraine nous agirons
toujours en parfaite coordination avec
nos partenaires et nos alliés et ça me
tâte
il est acquis